Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder.
Wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder.
So Leute, um geht's.
Soll ich euch mal was sehr trauriges sagen.
Mein Amazon Fire HD 8 hat Apps wieder deaktiviert, die ich schon längst deaktiviert hatte.
Was dazu geführt hat, dass ich jetzt massig Amazon Ads Spam auf meinem Tablet hab.
Ich muss erstmal wieder alle Apps deaktivieren.
Und den Fehler, den ich gemacht hab, ist, mich bei Amazon Video einzuloggen.
Das heißt, wenn man sein Amazon Tablet deploatet und entamazonifiziert hat
und man loggt sich bei einer Amazon App einmalig ein, dann muss man das Ganze nochmal machen.
Das ist natürlich Big Brain von Amazon.
Was sagt?
Was ziemlich sagt.
Was kostet eigentlich Feuerwerk so?
Ich mach keinen Feuerwerk, aber was kostet denn das aktuell so?
Feuerwerk, Set, Aldi.
Keine Ahnung, was kostet das denn? Ist das teuer geworden?
Easy, 227 Euro.
Ah, yes.
1712 Euro.
Warum ist das so teuer?
Excellent Price.
Mein Chat ist übrigens gerade kaputt, ne?
Das nur.
So, jetzt geht er wieder.
Alter, ist das teuer? Ist das so teuer? Was ist das?
Warum kostet das 30 Milliarden Euro?
Ach so, das ist irgend so ein Profi Zeug oder so.
Okay.
Das ist ganz schön teuer, oder?
Das ist ganz schön teuer.
Moment.
Ah, anstatt dass ich selbst Feuerwerk mache,
also ich mache ja keinen Feuerwerk, aber anstatt dass ich selbst Feuerwerk mache,
kann man sich den großen Feuerwerksimulator kaufen.
Das ist natürlich auch exzellent.
Ich brauche jetzt den VECO-Firework-Simulator.
Gibt es davon? Ich brauche davon unbedingt Screenshots.
Ist immer ein...
Naja, gut.
Vor allem die Häuser sehen absolut hochdetailliert aus.
Ah, das ist Yoshi Musik.
Dieser Realismus ist ja huge.
Aber eine Nocturlüfter drauf, beste.
Top 10 der Story Games von 2019.
Das gucken wir uns dann alles an Silvester an, als Zeugs.
Vielleicht mal copy-pasten.
Silvester gucken wir uns an, was es für gescheite Games gibt nächstes Jahr
und was dieses Jahr so abgekackt ist.
Vielleicht nicht alles an Silvester. Vielleicht nicht alles.
So früh? Ja, 10? Du bist ja immer so in dem Treter.
Ich kann mein Notizprogramm nicht starten, was mich sehr wundert gerade.
Warum geht das nicht?
So, wir fangen mal an.
Wir fangen mal ein bisschen was zu gucken.
Und zwar, weil zum Einstieg gucken wir uns die Top Plays der Battlefield Top Plays an.
Also das ist so richtig Top Play Inception.
Ja, der Eichler, ich sag ja, ich kann mir das kaum vorstellen,
dass er wirklich da sein komisches Fiber Ding überall verwendet.
Aber gucken wir uns mal die Top Plays der Top Plays an, so zur Einstimmung.
Hier ist es, Battlefield 1. Nee, 2.
Geh fort.
Battlefield 1, geh fort.
Ok, Battlefield Physik, beste.
Ich hoffe, das sind alle Battlefields, weil ich meine das heißt...
Ach Moment, es ist best of 2000 Battlefield 5 Top Plays.
Will ich die Battlefield 5 Top Plays? Hat er auch eine 2019 Top Battlefield Plays?
Ach nee, ist doch, oder?
Ist alles Battlefield 5, das ist ja doof.
Deshalb hab ich gar keinen Bock zu gucken.
Das ist Battlefield 3.
Gucken wir lieber Battlefield 3 Top Plays, bevor wir uns Battlefield 5 Top Plays angucken.
Was passiert? Ich hab es euch mitgekriegt.
Ich bin nicht ganz sicher.
Battlefield 5 nicht so beliebt ist bei mir nicht, ich spiel's halt nicht.
Der hat natürlich den Big Brain Name.
Ja, so sieht's aus.
Das kennen wir, oder? Das kommt mir bekannt vor.
Ja, das haben wir schon gesehen.
Ist aber langsam eng.
Wir haben schon alles geguckt.
Dann gucken wir uns jetzt was Altes Battlefield 3 an.
Also was das alt.
3-4 Monate.
Das ist eine absolute Lieblingsmap.
Der Akte war wahrscheinlich keine so gute Idee.
Die Gegner sind halt wieder absolut brain dead.
Die Gegner sind halt wieder absolut brain dead, aber das ist ein sehr neischer Streak.
Franzose.
Nee, da war schon ein bisschen Glück dabei.
Busy, nur ganz klar ist busy.
Aber das war schon predictable, das war nicht einfach mal random geschossen.
Da eskalieren nur alle.
So einen Scheiß kannst du halt echt nur in Battlefield machen.
Und ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob man sowas überhaupt in Battlefield 1 und 5 machen kann.
Hat nicht so ganz funktioniert, hä?
What?
Das war Glück.
War auch ne coole Map.
Die Leute wieder.
Ich bin der krasse Sniper, ich sitze aufm Hochhaus und krieg von der Welt herum nichts mit.
Das ist genau so wie dieser Typ.
Genauso stelle ich mir den 0815 Sniper Noob vor.
Genau wie dieser Typ.
Moment, springt jetzt wieder in den Chat.
Geil, da springt wieder in den Chat rein.
Das ist natürlich nice.
Das war richtig cool.
Dass der Chat genau an der Stelle wieder runter kommt, wo er den Typ killt.
Das ist nice.
Das ist wieder sowas, wo ich mir denke, okay, war das Setup?
Oder war das halt einfach Riesenglück?
Das war auf jeden Fall nice.
Okay, Sellout überspringen wir mal.
M16.
Erstmal schön OP-Gun.
Aber warum nicht?
Das war halt das Coole an Battlefield 3, dass du durch die Gegner durchspringen konntest.
Sonst hätte das überhaupt nicht funktioniert.
Und jetzt sauber ein bisschen mit der Magnum drauf.
Das ist halt einfach nice zu gucken.
Der Schneiber wieder nichts gecheckt.
Aber du brauchst dumme Gegner, es geht keiner anders.
Ich fand das cool.
Kidswitchen fand ich in Bad Company 2 richtig geil.
Das ist wieder der Schneiber-Typ da hinten, der nicht in der Lage ist, ihn zu treffen.
Ja, stimmt, Ejax, du hast schon ganz schön oft durchgeschossen.
Und manchmal hast du auch Sachen getroffen, wo ich mir gedacht habe, warum hat er das jetzt genau gehittert?
Teilweise 5 Sekunden später.
Aber Battlefield 3 war halt einfach nice.
Mittlerweile muss man sagen, glaube ich, ich habe hier schon eine Weile nicht mehr gespielt, ist Battlefield 4 auch richtig gut.
Aber ich habe keinen Bock mehr wieder mit dem Uralspiel anzufangen jetzt.
Wisst ihr Leute, es sind ja gerade Service-Games voll angesagt.
Nach dem Motto, wir bringen jetzt ein Game raus, das wird dann über 3 Jahre update, guckt euch Rainbow Six oder so etwas in die Richtung an.
Ich hätte echt keine Probleme, die würden ein ordentliches Battlefield rausbringen und das ein bisschen mehr Verservice-Gamifizieren.
Weil ich hätte mir bei Battlefield 3 beispielsweise gerne, also hätte ich gerne mehr und habe mir gewünscht, dass da länger mehr Content kommt.
Also länger in der Zeit her und auch insgesamt mehr Content.
Und bei Battlefield 4 irgendwo auch.
Aber da hätte ich überhaupt keine Schmerzen, das können die ruhig machen.
Das Problem ist nur, ich habe keinen Bock, das mit Battlefield 5 zu machen.
Sollen sie es mit Battlefield 3 machen und dafür in Ordnung.
Aber das Base-Game muss halt gut sein.
Wenn das Base-Game nicht gut ist, bringt einem noch so viel Service-Game-Geschichte nichts.
Also generell bringt einem Service-Game ein bisschen weniger Geld in der Tasche in der Regel.
Aber sieht man an Anthem, Anthem hat ein Base-Game-Crap und alles, was danach gekommen ist, ist halt auch nicht dadurch gut.
Wenn das Base-Game schon Crap ist, was willst du dann mit inhalten?
Dann brauchst du dann wie bei No Man's Sky 85.000 Jahre, bis das Game halbwegs taugt.
Der No-Scoped.
Warum hat er das Messer getroffen? Das Messer war irgendwo am Arsch der Welt.
Deswegen muss das Game von Anfang an richtig gut sein, dass die Player-Base geil ist auf mehr Content und auch da bleibt.
Was in Battlefield 3 ja funktioniert hat, trotz hat es nicht so viel Content.
Also neun.
Die raffen gar nichts, ne. Die raffen null.
Das sind doch nicht mal Weihnachtsnoups in so alten Games, das sind einfach Kack-Noups.
Durch und durch.
Ja, No Man's Sky hat die Kurve gekriegt.
Oh, er retzt.
Ich darf das Video von ihm zeigen, alles gut.
Ne, ich hab den noch nicht gekauft, ich weiß auch nicht, ob ich's wirklich mache.
Oh nice, schön reingesprayt und wie der Gegner die links gecheckt haben, aber das muss so sein.
Er war schön zwischen den Getränken, aber leider down.
Also jetzt geht es nochmal weiter.
Aber das ist halt das Geile an den alten Battlefield-Teilen, oder an den älteren Battlefield-Teilen gewesen.
Du konntest durchaus ganz okay sein, die restliche Runde.
Das war dann aber jetzt nicht so das Heile, aber manchmal hast du halt einfach so richtig krasse Dinge gehabt, wo du dann um die Ecke gelaufen bist
und das haben alle Gegner weggeguckt, du hattest eine LMG und es standen zwanzig Gegner vor dir gefühlt
und die haben alle nicht hingeguckt, du hast angefangen, du hast das leer gesprayt und fast alles gekillt.
War das eine Pick-Up-Waffe oder konnte man die ausrüsten in Battlefield 4?
War das Pick-Up-Waffe oder konnte man das ausrüsten?
Pick-Up.
Das war schon eines der Punkte, die ich an Battlefield 4 doof fand mit dem Pick-Up-Waffe.
Na?
Wo ist der da jetzt im Typwerk?
Hä?
Das war halt bisschen Prediction und ziemlich viel Glück.
Ja gut, das war halt pures Glück.
Ich mein, guckt euch mal den Gegner an.
Ich mein, wie beknackt, wie beknackt muss man eigentlich sein, jetzt, jetzt Achtung, jetzt,
anstatt auf den Gegner zu schießen, den Defi raus zu holen und mein Team wieder zu beleben.
Wie?
Das tut einfach weh.
Einfach auf den Gegner schießen, gut für GWZ, keine Chance gehabt, da hatte ich gerade mit jemand anderem beschäftigt.
Aber nee, erstmal den Defi rausfuddeln und direkt vor der Nase wieder beleben.
Ja, dem geht das wohl nicht aus, wahrscheinlich, keine Ahnung, was der vorhatte.
Aber gut, ohne Gegner, die mithelfen, klappt sowas halt nicht.
Das Video hat ganz huge Bitrate gerade.
Das wär so eine Serie, die würd ich auch gerne machen, ey.
Irgendwie, weiß nicht.
Es gibt so viel 3- und 4-Top-Plays, so voll random einfach nur im Jahr 2020.
4-Top-Play ist noch nicht.
Weiß nicht.
Auf dem Server spiel ich auch öfters.
Wenn ich denn, wenn ich denn, also öfters ist bisschen übertrieben.
Jetzt wird er erst mal Crossbow, oder?
Haha, und jetzt wieder einsteigen.
Er hat aber versucht, den Typ rauszusnipen und wieder einzusteigen.
Aber das Wieder-Einsteigen hat nicht funktioniert, aber trotzdem geil.
Was ist das da, Fox?
Ah, nice.
Seid ihr worden, ja, so zur Einstimmung, ne?
Mit wie viel FPS hat er aufgenommen, 5?
Slow-Motion mit 5 FPS, oh Gott.
Ich seh, ich seh vor lauter Bildern nichts, was passiert, ey.
Gear-Show.
Okay, das war auch sehr glücklich jetzt.
Das war schon Absicht, aber auch wahnsinnig viel Glück wieder dabei.
Vom Klaus?
Aber das ist die, also ich muss sagen, das ist die
advancedeste Schreibweise von Klaus, die ich je gesehen habe, ey.
Hä?
Ach, der hat einen gekillt, okay, das hab ich gar nicht mitgekriegt.
Ah, gut.
Die haben wahrscheinlich die ganze Runde nichts anderes gemacht da oben.
Die ganze Woche, ja, wahrscheinlich die ganze Woche.
Schon wieder.
Schon wieder, das ist die gleichen Typen an der gleichen Stelle.
Die haben wahrscheinlich wirklich wieder eher gesagt, die ganze Runde in Spawn geschossen
und gehofft, dass sie was treffen.
Da stehen sie auch da mit der Munikiste.
Ich seh nix, ich seh nix.
Also, dass der da hingeflogen ist, da hab ich schon ganz schön Glück dabei.
Ah, Battlefield-Physik.
Battlefield-Physik.
Oh, nice.
Aber halt auch Glück ohne Ende, aber nice.
So sagten sie immer cool, das hat er auch jetzt drei Monate probiert.
Bam, nice.
Und wieder einsteigen, oh cool.
Das ist immer cool, wenn das klappt.
Das ist immer nice zu sehen.
Scheiß auf Realismus, oder?
Viel besser.
Ich spiel das nicht, dass es realistisch ist.
Der ist reingeflohen von hinten, ey.
Fecht gehabt.
Das ist Battlefield 3, oder?
So blau, wie das ist.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ich fand auch die Funk-Sounds und alles cool.
Da hätten sie mal nen Service-Game draus machen sollen, das drei Jahre supporten.
Jetzt hätte ich aber auch alles bis jetzt hergekriegt.
Also Gameplay in der Richtung hatte ich auch genug.
Hätte ich vielleicht auch mal einschicken sollen.
Ich mein, der geht schon gut ab hier.
Und die Gegner rennen eben gerade rein.
Und es geht auch ganz schön lang.
Aber das ist schon nice.
Das ist einfach geil zu gucken, Battlefield 3-Gegner wegsprayen.
Ich find auch die Sounds, wenn du die Gegner killst, bei Battlefield 3 teilweise richtig geil.
Und erstmal der Red's Train läuft an.
Ja, natürlich. Wenn die Gegner wüssten, was abgeht, würden solche Clips ja auch nicht gehen.
Bam!
Headshot fand ich schon immer übel schwierig in Battlefield.
Was ist Epicenter?
Das sieht aus wie Epicenter.
Man könnte auch...
Oder ist das doch nicht Epicenter?
Doch, sieht aus wie Epicenter, aber hm...
Mir fällt jetzt nicht an, was es sonst sein könnte.
Nee, das ist nicht Epicenter.
Ich hab aber keine Ahnung, wie die Map heißt.
Nee, Talamarkt war es nicht. Talamarkt, da hab ich auch dran gedacht.
Talamarkt ist mehr gelb.
Oder vielleicht war es auch Talamarkt.
Der sagt auch bei jedem Clip das gleiche, der Typ.
Was geht mit der Musik ab jetzt?
Was mache ich mit den Punkten? Einfach ausgeben.
Hands to Aqua.
Ja, einer der wenigen Leute, die ich tatsächlich sowohl von YouTube als auch persönlich kenne.
Ja, nicht so viele.
Minus 380.
Azardi Palace, das kann sein, ja.
Ja, ja.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich noch dunkel dran erinnere.
So, Hydraten, 6 Monate, Dankeschön, Pock.
Ja, leider macht der Battlefield 5 und Battlefield 5 guck ich mir nicht gerne an.
Der ging durch hier.
Geht er immer noch weiter?
Was ich mich frage immer, wenn ich sowas sehe, hat dieses kurz in die Ironsides reinzoomen?
Hat das wirklich was für die Accuracy gebracht oder war das einfach nur Angewohnheit, die man so hatte?
Ja, mache ich, mache ich.
Black Mesa hat die Xen-Levels, da müssen wir uns unbedingt angucken.
Battlefield 5 sieht gut aus, aber ich mag Battlefield 5 an sich nicht.
Vom Game. Optisch sieht das Ding immer gut aus.
Ich könnte mir, ich mache mir einfach einen neuen EA-Account, den nenne ich OK Boomer und spiele nur alte Battlefields damit.
Das wäre doch mal was.
Der ist ja mit dem Kopf quasi reingesprungen in das Fadenkreuz gerade.
Kann man auch Battlefield 2 spielen? Ja, theoretisch schon, aber ich weiß nicht, ob es auch Server gibt.
Weil die haben ja den ursprünglichsten Server, der ist abgeschaltet.
Ihr habt einen Heli getroffen, jetzt kriegt euch mal ab.
Nice Compilation.
Ok, also was gucken wir dann als nächstes? Was haben wir denn zu bieten?
Ich habe ein paar Videos aufgemacht, die wir gucken können.
Wir können uns die Windows Ads von Windows 1 bis Windows 10 angucken.
Wir können uns Javascript in just 5 Minuten, warum habe ich das denn offen?
In 5 Minutes Javascript, ok.
Worst Games of 2019, Black Mesa Xen Review, das müssen wir auf jeden Fall gucken.
Worst Console Lounge Ever, Google Stadia, das müssen wir uns auch angucken.
Ich bin gespannt, wie da rumgeflamed wird.
Sagt ihr Venise Unleashed was? Ja, aber das ist ja nie fertig geworden.
Das letzte Update ist von 4 Jahren oder so.
20 Overhyped Games und wir können uns ein neues Electro Boom Video angucken.
Worst Games, ok, wir gucken uns Worst Games an und dann gucken wir uns Worst Console Lounge an.
Hat der CCC schon was interessantes hochgeladen?
Ja, das mit der Gesundheitsakte ist ganz ok, aber der Vortrag ist ein bisschen konfus.
Und das Bahnmining gestern war richtig gut.
Wieso englische Sprache bei Windows ganz einfach?
Dass wenn man Probleme hat, man einfacher nach Fehlern suchen kann.
2019 ist los, so wie immer machen wir ein paar Listen, die die besten und schlimmsten Games dieses Jahr machen.
Und heute sind es leider die schlimmsten Games von 2019.
Die, die wir uns am meisten nicht mögen.
Hör auf, das sind unsere persönlichen Entscheidungen.
Haben wir doch, wir haben doch letztens schon mal eine Liste gemacht.
Wir haben noch letztens schon mal eine Liste gemacht.
Also wir schauen uns auf, was ihr denkt in den Kommentaren.
Einerseits, wie ihr seht, fangen wir mit Nummer 10 an.
Viele Monitore, zwei hier nebeneinander.
Was?
Was, es gab ein neues Contra?
Warum müssen die eigentlich klassische Game-Serien, die eigentlich ganz gut waren, immer verkacken?
Mit irgendwelchen komischen Reboots.
Ach, war das das mit dem Panda-Beer?
War das das mit dem Panda-Beer, wo ich mich gefragt habe, warum ist da ein Panda-Beer drinnen?
Ach so, Chat-Overlay, klar.
Chat-Overlay, das haben wir ja gestern ausgemacht.
Hab ich mir vergessen einzuschalten.
Chat-Overlay muss sein.
Gibt es da Dances?
Braucht jedes Game-Side-Fortnite-Dances?
Oh.
Konami in 2019.
Was?
Außerdem sind Film-Umsetzungen meistens kacke.
Residenz Leaper, klingt das.
Können die auch mal Games?
Können die auch mal Games irgendwie, da, von denen ich schon mal was gehört hab?
Ich glaube, ich hab noch nie ein Volleyball-Game gespielt.
Warum auch?
Vor allem diese tollen Gesichts-Animationen.
Moins Giro.
Huge Animation.
Ihh, FIFA.
Nee, aber die müssen, die sind vertraglich verpflichtet, ein Spiel für die Konsole zu releasen.
Ob sie das jetzt wollen oder nicht, die müssen.
Dementsprechend wird da auf den Konsolen, wo sie keinen großen Fokus drauf legen, wird,
ich mein, FIFA ist eh schon der Cash Crap ohne Ende, wird echt das absolut minimalste
vom Praktikanten in der Mittagspause beim Kacken programmiert.
Warum müssen die das? Weil das an die Lizenzbedingungen hängt.
Also sie sind, sie haben sich das ja gekauft und ein Teil dieser Lizenzbestimmung ist,
dass die jede Konsole bis, frag mich nicht, die irgendwie eine gewisse Verbreitung hat,
müssten sie ein FIFA rausbringen.
Warum kackt der in der Mittagspause nicht während der Arbeitszeit?
Weil er während seiner Arbeitszeit jetzt andere FIFA programmieren muss.
Okay, lass uns mal ein tolles Nutzsystem einbauen, was keiner braucht.
Es fehlt alles High Quality, was sie mehr oder weniger direkt vom Vorgänger übernommen haben.
Ich hab bis heute nicht gecheckt, ob sie das Geld überwiesen haben mittlerweile für den
Sellout, muss ich mal machen.
Nicht, dass ich es umsonst Sellout gemacht habe.
Es ist designed sinnlose Mechaniken zu haben, dass man das upgraden kann.
Das ist ja das Aufgesetzte überhaupt.
Diese komischen Survival Aspekte, die mit dem Game überhaupt nichts zu suchen haben.
Ich glaube, es ist das erste so richtige Nintendo Cash Crab Mobile Transaction Game.
Wie es bei Pokemon aussieht, weiß ich nicht, ob das da so schlimm ist.
Aber das ist einfach nur da, um Microtransactions zu haben.
Nee, das Super Mario Runner nicht.
Das kaufst du einmal und dann kannst du spielen.
Mario Run ist gar nicht schlecht.
Man darf ja nicht denken, man fährt hier großartig.
Du fährst zum größten Teil automatisch.
Du kannst doch nicht von der Strecke fallen oder so.
Das sieht nur so aus, als würde man fahren.
Man fährt gar nicht wirklich.
Cut and Draw, drei Monate.
Big Prime Stop.
Hab ich noch nie was von gehört.
Dachte mir gar nichts.
Hab ich schon nie was von gehört.
Ist aber anscheinend auch nicht schlimm.
Wenn ich das Menü schon sehe, Leute, wenn ich solche, das sind Menüs.
Das sind Menüs, die man mal während der Entwicklung macht, damit man selbst ein Menü hat und das Menü ausprobieren kann.
Aber das sind doch keine Menüs, die man in ein fertiges Game packt.
Man kann ziemlich gut, finde ich jetzt, man kann ziemlich gut anhand von Ingame Menüs erkennen, welchen Polish und wie viel Mühe gibt Status ein Game hat.
Und das hier hat kein.
Alex, danke schön.
Das ist wirklich, das ist, das ist total kaputt, das Game.
Das ist total kaputt.
Ich glaube, es gab wenige Games, wo es so viele, also dieses Jahr, wo es so viele Klitsch Kompilations irgendwie gab, wie dazu.
Die zeigen ja überhaupt kein Rumgeklitsche.
Es ist übelst kaputt, ey.
Ja, also schön sieht es nicht aus.
Schaut euch mal den Tisch an und die Pflanze da hinten, und den Raum allgemein.
Und vor allem, warum hat der Dude da irgendwie ein Tablet hängen, was macht das da?
Also, so wie ich das in Videos gesehen habe, klitscht man da auch ganz gerne mal durch den Boden und sowas. Und vor allem, was richtig abgedreht aussieht, ist, wenn sie in den Seilen hängen bleiben.
H-Physik war eben huge.
Ja, das war auch in unserer Top 10 Worst Liste drin.
Der eine, du weißt es schon, moin. Das war verkackt, Anthem, Alter.
Die wussten ja während der Entwicklung nicht, was es werden soll, und genau so fühlt sich das an.
Das ist das, was ich, das sage ich ja auch immer, bei dieser ganzen Service-Game-Thematik.
Damit man das überhaupt in Erwägung ziehen kann, muss das Base-Game richtig gut sein.
Hätte man zum Beispiel Battlefield 3 genommen und gesagt, hey, man strickt da jetzt in drei Jahren das Content-Plan,
und will dafür öfters auch mal Kohle haben, oder irgendwelche, die in ein Abo passen, oder irgendwas und so. Vollkommen okay, weil das Base-Game gut war. Aber was halt immer scheiße ist, wenn das Base-Game suckt und du es danach halbwegs gut machst,
da sind die Leute schon längst weggerannt, dass das bei Rainbow Six so gut geklappt hat, grenzt an ein Wunder für mich schon irgendwie.
Weil das war am Anfang auch nicht so geil, da sind viele Leute wieder abgesprungen, aber dadurch, dass sie das relativ schnell in den Griff gekriegt haben und jetzt auch relativ lange,
sind halt viele Leute wieder hingekommen, weil sie halt gesehen haben, okay, die haben das Vertrauen zurückgewonnen da drinnen. Aber bei sowas ist halt komplett für den Arsch.
Die sind halt weg, die könnten jetzt, die könnten da jetzt den besten Patch aller Zeiten raushauen mit ihren fünf Spielern oder so, die sie noch haben, juckt das halt keinem mehr.
Dafür wusste Destiny von Anfang an, was er es machen will.
Auch wenn der Endgame Content war, Destiny halt auch, naja.
Was war denn das? War das die Metal Gear Stealth Game?
Na dann. Ja, das war das, was dann total abgekackt hat.
Haben wir letztens schon mal gesehen. Guck mal, wie sich die Gegner nicht checken.
Krasse AI.
Die Animation sieht doch übelst freudig aus. Und diese Lauf-Animation.
Ja, das sieht aus wie ein 360-Game, was am Anfang der Generation rausgekommen ist.
Aber ich hab das gar nicht so sehr verfolgt, aber das taucht in ganz vielen Listen auf und scheint was dran zu sein.
Okay, und jetzt gucken wir den Worst Console Lounge Google Stadia. Mal gucken, also es hat gemischte Bewertung.
Gucken, ob der einfach nur rumflamed oder auch was, also das ist die Stadia Werbung, ob der auch was sagen kann.
Uncharted 1 sah besser aus. Generell sah Uncharted extrem gut aus.
Hast du deine Stadia jetzt? Ich hab die abgestattet. Negativ Latency, sag ich nur.
Oh nee, ist das so ein YouTube-Mensch, der rumschreit? Dann mach ich das gleich wieder aus.
Ja, das ist so. Das Video ist gut. Okay, dann gucken wir das. Wenn der Chat das sagt.
Der schreit gleich richtig laut, ich hoffe nicht. Der ist schon so richtig, das ist so ein typischer YouTube-Mensch einfach.
Von der ganzen Art, wie da geredet wird. Na klar, na klar ist das fair.
Die werben ja selbst damit, dass sie die bessere Alternative sind und vor allem, dass sie quasi enttäuscht werden, wenn sie nur so viele Spiele hätten wie eine PS4 und sowas in der Richtung.
Natürlich kann man das verkleiden. Muss man sogar.
Da haben sie sich auch wieder was zurecht gerechnet.
Da ist ja gut, erzähl einfach was, du übertreibst nicht so.
Ja, wenn es nicht funktionieren würde.
Oh ja.
Ja, das stimmt. Zumal der Vergleich übelst fail ist.
Ja, zu was, was bei dir unter dem Tisch steht und zu was, was in dem Rack hängt in dem Rechenzentrum. Also der Vergleich hat damals schon sehr gehinkt.
Und von wann ist denn das Video, ist das ja doch ist aktuell.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen X6 nach X64, wie viel in die Register reinpasst.
Das könnte man am Anfang denken, aber war eigentlich relativ schnell klar, dass es eher nicht so wird.
Alter, reg dich ab. YouTube 2019.
Aber ich habe es abgestellt. Und ich habe es abgestellt nicht, weil ich denke und was ich, ich bin ja jeder Meinung, das wird failen und demnächst auf dem Google Friedhof landen.
Aber ich habe es abgestellt, weil ich glaube ich zwei Monate oder so vorher eine Founders Edition geordert habe und die wollten mir ernsthaft erzählen, das Ding kommt einen Monat ungefähr. Ich habe sie auf Twitter gepostet.
Irgendwie einen Monat, drei Wochen oder so, nach Release. Und da habe ich mir gedacht, Alter, wenn ich den Scheiß 2,5 Monate vorher bestellt habe und ich bekomme es drei Wochen oder so nach Release, was ist denn das für ein Crap.
Das sehe ich nicht ein. Ganz ehrlich, warum machen sie sowas überhaupt zum Vorbestellen, wenn du es da nicht kriegst. Das ist total hängen geblieben einfach nur.
Und ich bestelle selten Sachen ab. Ja, das stimmt.
Aber zurück zu dem, was du in diesem Bundel bekommst. Was ist Stadia Pro? Du glaubst, es ist ein monatlicher Preis, um eine ganze Liga von Spielen zu spielen, oder?
Well, es ist nicht. Stadia Pro ist eigentlich ein monatlicher Preis, das angeboten ist, das dir ein paar freie Spiele geben lässt und dir die Möglichkeit gibt, Stadia in voller Qualität zu spielen. Das stimmt, Leute. Stadia kann nur bei den besprochenen 4K an 60FPS gespielt werden, wenn du eine zusätzliche Fee pro Monat bezahlen kannst.
Die PS4 kostet nur monatlich, wenn du online spielen willst. Wenn du einfach nur Singleplayer Spiele spielen willst, was ganz viele Leute machen wollen, musst du bei der PS4 nichts bezahlen.
Naja, die ursprüngliche Idee war,
dass du keine Hardware von Google dafür brauchst, um es benutzen zu können, sondern dass du einfach, sagen wir mal, deinen normalen Rechner nimmst, Browser aufmachst und spielen kannst.
So war das gedacht. Aktuell, ich weiß nicht, ob es immer noch so ist, sie wollen ja davon weg, also es soll ja geöffnet werden, aktuell brauchst du das offizielle Bundle mit dem Chromecast drin. Kannst du das nicht einfach auf deinem Desktop spielen?
Das wollen sie machen, ja, aber so wie es aktuell ist, stelle ich mir da unter so einer Cloud-Gaming-Lösung schon ein bisschen was anderes vor.
Das geht doch eigentlich, es soll gehen, aber beim Release ging es nicht. Beim Release musstest du das mit dem Chromecast spielen, oder ich glaube, mit dem Chromebook ging auch. Ich glaube, es ging drei Sachen, den Chromebook, ein aktuelles Handy von Google oder Chromecast.
Ich glaube, diese drei Sachen gingen am Anfang. Du konntest nicht einfach mit dem Browser hin.
Stadia, gucken wir doch mal, gucken wir doch mal.
Ja, aktuell nur Support für Pixel. Sicher, du brauchst ein aktuelles Google-Handy.
Premiere Edition.
Ja, du brauchst diesen Chromecast, wenn du es auf dem Fernseh spielen willst. Ich google Chromecast Ultra mit 4K.
Genau, Twitch-Zuschauer, ganz genau, das muss, das muss hardwareunabhängig sein. Was sind das für eine bescheuerte Lösung?
So, und jetzt können wir mal gucken. Was soll ich oben gucken? Smartphones? Ja, guck, genau.
Du brauchst einen Chromecast. Ja, wo soll ich gucken?
Bis zu 60 FPS, ja, Porgasser.
Was über kaufen? Wenn du es kaufen willst, musst du dir einen Chromecast kaufen. Das geht aktuell, das soll mal in Zukunft gehen.
Stadia, Chrome, Windows. Play Stadia on Chrome. Okay.
Geht das schon? Das probieren wir jetzt aus.
Wäre cool, wenn das jetzt schon funktioniert.
Am Anfang musstest du das mit diesem, du konntest das am Anfang, konntest du das auf einem Chromebook machen, auf einem Handy und mit diesem komischen Chromecast.
By now. Nee, die wollen unbedingt, dass ich diesen Kram kaufe.
Wie kann ich das mit Chrome spielen?
Launch Stadia on Web by visiting using Google Chrome. Sign up. Sign in. Ah. Was, du musst dich per Handyapp, genau, und per Handyapp, das ging aber dann auch über das iPhone, ne?
Das habe ich gelesen, du konntest, die iPhone Stadia App kann aktuell nur Sign in, sonst nichts.
Play Stadia, Chrome, Windows.
Here's a rundown on how to play Stadia on PC. Okay. Requires Google Chrome. Das ist ja klar, da habe ich jetzt auch nicht anders mit gerechnet.
controls by default. Warum sollte ich denn überhaupt diese komische Hardware kaufen?
Ach, das war's. Okay, man kann es auf dem PC spielen, aber die höchste Einstellung geht nur mit dem Chromecast. Was auch irgendwie sehr merkwürdig ist, ne?
Irgendwann 2020 eventuell mal. Trotzdem, hey, Pott, du bist doch von Arsch. Es ist halt wirklich 10 von 10, wenn man Google-Muslimer in Stadia spielen kann. Ja, leider sind viele Google-Services so. Ich meine, guckt euch mal die Google-Account-Settings an.
Das ist eine gute Frage, Albino Black Sheep. Er sagt, weil ich bin gerade durch Zufall auf den Stream gestoßen und würde auch gerne mal meinen Self dazu abgeben.
Ich verstehe nicht, warum auf Stadia so rumgehackt wird. Es ist halt neue Technik und muss erstmal optimiert werden. Früher gab es ja auch keine Autos mit 500 PS, genau so sehe ich das auch hier.
Dass man an einem Fernseh spielen kann, braucht man eben noch so einen Chromecast, finde ich überhaupt nicht schlimm. Am PC braucht man doch einfach nur Google Chrome. Wo ist das Problem?
Das Problem ist, was ich da aktuell dran sehe, es ist erstens keine neue Technik in dem Sinn. Das gibt es seit 10 Jahren schon. Den riesen Vorteil, den Google hat, ist, dass die halt die Infrastruktur drum herum haben, das Ganze machen zu können.
Und was war das andere? Achso, warum auf Stadia so rumgehackt wird bzw. neue Technik optimiert werden? Na ja, Google hat halt selbst auf richtig dicke Hose gemacht.
So nach dem Motto Negative Latency, dass es quasi besser ist als die anderen Plattformen, die vergleichen sich ja direkt mit anderen Plattformen, dann erzählen sie so Sachen wie, dass sie quasi fast schon enttäuscht wären, wenn sie nur so wenige Spieler wie auf der Playstation hätten und sowas in der Richtung.
Also im Prinzip, die wollen ja, die wollen ja gemessen werden an dem, was bei anderen schon geht. Sie sind da selbst dran schuld, hätten die bisschen kleinere Brötchen gebacken, dann würden sie sich nicht so viel darüber beschweren, aber ich meine, man kann sich ja über das beschweren, was sie angepriesen haben und was halt nicht so ist.
Nö, dass man nur 60 FPS hat, ist nicht schlimm.
60 FPS für die normalen, das ist kein Ding für die meisten Dinger, aber ich hab's ja ganz am Anfang schon gesagt, als sie das damals, das allererste Google Stadia Zeug, was sie angekündigt haben, ich hab gesagt, ich kauf denen ihr ganze Latency Versprechen erst ab, sobald ein CS Team, ein Major auf Stadia gewinnt.
Dann kauf ich ihnen ihre Latency Versprechen ab. Und Leute, soll ich euch mal spoilern, das werden wir wahrscheinlich nie sehen.
Die haben ja am Anfang so riesen Versprechungen gemacht, ich mein, negative Latency, allein schon wie hirnverbrannt diese Versprechung gewesen ist. Negative Latency, also ich mein, hat Google jetzt irgendwie eine neue Physik erfunden oder haben die irgendwie festgestellt, dass es doch schneller geht als die Lichtgeschwindigkeit?
Was sie damit gemeint haben, sie haben schon das genau damit gemeint, sie wollten es auch so dastehen lassen, von der Logik her sagen sie ja, okay, Negative Latency heißt ja quasi, wenn alle jetzt bei Stadia zusammen Multiplayer spielen, dann ist die Verbindung innerhalb von Stadia schneller, weil die Leute müssen ja nicht mehr von zu Hause übers Internet zu einem Server und vom Server zu den Mitspielern, sondern sind direkt in Stadia drinnen.
Das Problem bei der Sache ist nur, die wichtigste, die mit Abstand wichtigste Latency, die es in einem Game gibt, ist Action, also Aktion, Reaktion.
Du musst so schnell wie möglich, wenn du was drückst, wenn du was machst, musst du das Feedback sehen und das ist das, wo halt Stadia nichts davon hat, wenn die anderen Mitspieler neben dir auf dem gleichen Server laufen.
Das mag dann im Endeffekt, wenn deine Daten dahingeschickt worden sind und quasi Multiplayer-Kommunikation mag das sein, aber das ist nicht so das Problem. Ich meine, guck mal, ich habe zu einem Battlefield-Server in Köln 8 Millisekunden Latency, als würde es das jetzt fett machen.
Wichtig ist, dass ich ordentlich, und das sind ein paar Kilobyte, die ich dahinter übertragen muss, also es ist deutlich einfacher, meine Spiele-Daten zu einem Battlefield-Server zurück zu übertragen, als einen kompletten 4K 60 FPS Video-Stream mit 15 MBit oder 20 MBit was das Ding an, ich weiß nicht, die paar Kilobyte Daten zu einem Battlefield-Server.
Also es ist viel einfacher, das responsive zu machen, wenn es bei mir auf dem Rechner läuft. Und wie gesagt, ihr ganzes Negative-Latency und sonst was Gelaber, das habe ich von Anfang an gesagt, ich glaube das denen erst, wenn ein CS-Team einen Major gewinnt auf Stadia, was halt nicht passieren wird.
Das, genau das Gefühl, genau das Gefühl habe ich auch Pluton an. Ein BWLer bei Google dachte, ich lasse uns auch Gaming machen. Genau so fühlt sich für mich Stadia an. Exakt so, hast du gut beschrieben.
Ich meine, hätten die jetzt, so wie das Royal Maroc sagt, hätten die jetzt gesagt, ok bei, warte mal, hätten die jetzt gesagt, hey bei einem Google Stadia Paket ist noch Google Fiber dabei und wir legen euch das Kabel.
Ja gut, dann hätte ich, dann hätte ich das ja geglaubt, dass das Technik besser geht. Was da natürlich infrastructure-mäßig nicht umsetzbar gewesen wäre. Aber da wäre es zumindest technisch irgendwie drin gewesen.
Und eins muss man auch sagen, es ist auch keine neue Technik, man kann das selbst machen. Weiß ich, ob ich euch das mal gezeigt habe. Das habe ich mit dem Fabian ein paar mal verwendet, um Spiele zusammen zu spielen.
Das ist richtig gut. Du kannst quasi auf deinem eigenen Windows Server ein paar Sack Server hosten. Ist das das überhaupt? Ja ich glaube das ist das, genau. Du kannst deine eigene Sache hosten und das ist tatsächlich relativ latency free, wenn du einen ordentlichen Internetanschluss hast.
Kann man, you cannot host on a Windows. Kann man hosten on Linux? Das muss ich unbedingt ausbringen, ob man Linux hosten kann. Da bin ich mal gespannt drauf.
Das muss ich mir mal nachher angucken. Also das geht ja anderweitig auch und der erste Service war glaube ich online vor vor 10 Jahren oder so, es ist ewig her, die das auch schon gemacht haben.
Die hatten natürlich nicht die Infrastruktur von Google, das ist klar. Das ist eigentlich der einzige riesen Vorteil, den Google Windows Stadia hat, ist ihre Infrastruktur, also sprich ihre Netzwerkinfrastruktur weltweit, ihre Rechenzentren weltweit und generell halt einfach ihre Hardware Power weltweit.
Das ist der riesen Vorteil, den Google Windows Stadia hat, ansonsten können die auch nicht zaubern. Merkt man bei Stadia eigentlich die Latenz im Spielen? Ich würde sagen es kommt auf die Spiele an.
Sag mal wenn man so Third Person Spiele wie Assassin's Creed hat oder so und der Server relativ nah dran ist, ist das denke ich, vielleicht merkt man das aber es ist nicht so gut spielbar, wirst du wirklich, wirst du was anspruchsvolles, schnelles, competitive Multiplayer spielen? Auf jeden Fall.
So, kommen wir mal weiter. Wo war man?
Es gibt, man muss halt sagen, es gibt überhaupt keinen Sinn. Es gibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, das habe ich schon, schön als auf Pause gelesen. Es gibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, dass man das über den Chromecast spielen muss.
Ich meine es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ein aktueller PC zu schlecht wäre, den 4K Stream abzuspielen. Es ist ja im Endeffekt der riesen Vorteil davon auch, du musst nichts mehr selbst berechnen, du musst einen 4K Stream abspielen. Das kann, das kann ein Fire TV.
Wenn den Typen ja schon sehr anstrengen, ja gäbe ich dir recht. Das ist so typischer, typischer YouTube Mensch halt.
Der Witz ist, dass auf dem iPhone kann man sich glaube ich die App nur verwenden, um sich einzuloggen. Ich glaube, zumindest bei dem letzten Review, was ich gesehen habe, war das so, dass du die iPhone App von Stadia zu nichts anderem verwenden kannst, als dich einzuloggen. Was natürlich auch ein bisschen fail ist, wozu gibt es deine App.
Quatschner, drei Monate, Twitch Prime, Big Prime Sub, Dankeschön. Ja, die meisten YouTube Menschen sind halt anstrengend.
Google hat halt einfach zu übertrieben.
Ja, ja, und das, und das war der Punkt, wo ich mein Stadia abgestellt habe.
Ich meine, warum heißt das Ding Founders Edition und du kannst es vorbestellen?
Nein, es gab noch ein Problem, das existierte, und das Problem war die Stadia Launch Codes. Jetzt, was können diese sein? Na ja, das sind Literale Codes, die Google dir via E-Mail schicken würde, um deinen Account zu aktivieren.
Ich glaube, das war der Punkt.
Ja, ja.
Ja, wahrscheinlich wohnt er einfach nur schlecht und der müsste einfach umziehen. Der wohnt einfach nur schlecht, das haben wir doch gestern im Vortrag gelernt.
Wobei das auch nur die halbe Wahrheit ist, der gleiche Typ hat, glaube ich, einen Tag später noch ein Video gemacht und hat gesagt, jetzt läuft es deutlich besser.
In Wirklichkeit genau, Sneaky Boy, du hast recht, in Wirklichkeit ist das hier der negative Input-Lag. In Wirklichkeit ist das nämlich nicht der Knopfdruck, der von ihm da angezeigt wird, sondern schon der übernächste Knopfdruck, der ihm angezeigt wird, bevor er den Knopf gedrückt hat.
Das ist es, Leute. Revealed. Es funktioniert alles, wir sind bloß zu blöd, es zu kapieren.
11 hat er.
Ja, das ist, ja gut, das ist halt, wenn der Stream, das ist halt so, wenn du einen Stream hast, wenn du einen Stream hast und nicht genug Frames kriegst, also Diffs, wenn du sogar ein Keyframe verpasst, das ist besonders bitter.
Alter, die, da kriegst du der Kopf weh.
Puffschkappos, ja.
Ist ja auch eine ganz, ja gut, es ist ja auch eine komplett andere Technik, was es unterm Strich nicht besser macht, weil gerade der, so der Charme von Stadia wäre ja eigentlich, dass es für Leute, die nicht so konsolenaffin oder sonst was sind, dass sie sich das einfach hinstellen können, keinen Rechner brauchen, sonst was spielen können, unterm Strich macht es das nicht besser. Warum es die Probleme gibt, ist auch klar, weil es eine komplett andere Technik ist.
Nein, mit einer 2K-Leitung, mit einer 2K-Leitung kannst du es komplett vergessen. Das ist auch eines der größten Probleme, die wir mit so Diensten wie Stadia in Deutschland haben, dass der Internet ausbaut.
Hey, es hat gewisse Ähnlichkeiten, oder?
Muss man mal sagen.
Also, ich schon?
Wer hätte das gedacht bei einem Google-Projekt, dass es nicht so gut funktioniert wie angepriesen?
Da hätte man überhaupt nicht drauf kommen können, das kann ich sagen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was dieser, dieser Vergleich hier ist so, so aus der Luft gegriffen. Mit was vergleichen die das denn bitteschön überhaupt? Das habe ich mich schon gefragt, also das ist das erste Mal angekündigt. Was ist das für ein Vergleich? Hier hast du eine Box unterm Schreibtisch stehen, da ist halt das an Hardware drinnen. Da hast du eine Box unterm Schreibtisch stehen, da ist halt das an Hardware drinnen. Hier hast du gar keine Box unterm Schreibtisch stehen und irgendwie in diesem Rechenzentrum läuft dein Spiel, also was ist das für ein Vergleich?
Ja, das macht mich glauben, dass Stadia etwas besser als die aktuellen Top-Systems runnt. Und mein PC sollte nicht sogar ein Kontender sein, weil, sagen wir mal, Super Computer Blade gegen eine Box in meinem Wohnzimmer. Super Computer sollte gewinnen, aber es geht nicht.
Instead of a console or a PC, you're using Google's data center as the platform. Stadia tends to run games at lower resolutions than I was led to believe. This was something I noticed right away when I started playing. Games simply didn't look that good. I'm talking obviously easy to see aliasing artifacts. That's the little jaggies you see all over the scene here. If I play similar...
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es gar nicht mal so sehr daran liegt, dass die wirklich, also vielleicht in niedrigeren Auslösungen liegen, aber die Spiele sind ja extra angepasst für Stadia. Und je nachdem, wie sie das gemacht haben, unterscheiden sich die Spiele im Output halt ein bisschen.
Aber klar, ich meine, auf dem PC-Lokal ist es schon eindeutig schärfer. Dazu kommt noch Kompression vom Stream. Aber das ist schon ein Riesenunterschied da. Guckt euch das mal an.
Ja, ja, ja. Ja, ja. Ja. Ja. Das ist nicht sofort.
ist games but you know what i think what he means is that the video stream is running at 4k
doesn't mean the game is so what you're getting is a lower quality game being broadcast at a higher
resolution this was something that i noticed but i wasn't alone the folks at digital foundry in
my opinion the community leaders of image quality analysis and video games also noticed these
problems and made it very clear in their videos that stadia wasn't running games at the resolutions
they were advertised to run at and if all of that wasn't enough proof and you needed just a little
bit more how about this one seit wann supported akron für kanae du brauchst ein extra gerät um in
4k zu spielen bungee the creators of destiny to themselves stated in an interview with the verge
that the game was running on stadia at 1080p not 4k and at the pc equivalent of about medium settings
i don't know about you folks but i'm starting to scale look maybe you've got an older platform
or console running destiny 2 or any other of these games and stadia may look better it's very
possible but that's not what stadia is supposed to be this platform is meant to be a giant leap
over modern systems not a small one and very soon its competition is going to get more fierce
with upcoming consoles like the xbox series x that may well be more powerful than what stadia is
currently demonstrating na ja man muss ja sagen wenn eine sache einfach ist bei stadia dann
ist es hardware upgrade das ist wirklich easy ich meine die müssen einfach nur ihre hardware
austauschen tonnen in die games besser auf und laufen besser ich muss mir eine neue konsole holen
dass das gleiche der fall ist so maybe power isn't what's gonna make this thing work gerade
deswegen ist auch dieser vergleich den sie da in ihrer präsentation hat total beknackt
of streaming games itself isn't stadia at least the leader in that remember how we talked about
playstation now early on die stadia bibliothek ist nicht gut but they also have a much more prolific
library 22 games on stadia at launch hundreds of games on playstation now and how can stadia compete
with that when they haven't even announced any first party in-house built and designed games
that's what stadia is all about the games i think it's pretty obvious to see that this whole event was
a massive series of problems that built to what can only be a failure of the launch despite the
many players out there who have fresh stadia wounds there are many others that had nothing
but sunshine and rainbows and there will likely be a core group of people who stand by stadia
moving forward considering it to be the best option for playing a whole bunch of video games
and that's fine stadia depends on your internet connection being consistent and solid and fast
enough to work all the time there are only a privileged few who can claim such stability
and even with all the internet connections i have access to that's still not a reality for me if you
think of stadia like a light switch and when you turn it on it didn't always turn on the lights
you wouldn't trust it right and i think that's what stadia is a light switch you can't trust i can't
give you an answer for the long-term success of stadia will stadia blaze a brave new trail into the gaming
history books or will it go the way of online cloud gaming service what's online you ask exactly my
point but whatever the result whatever the future holds whatever might happen whenever i think of
stadia i'll always think of one thing it having the worst console launch ever also wenn ihr mich
fragt wohin stadia hat er gefragt er gerade gefragt wohin headed stadia also wohin wohin
geht stadia ich kann euch das genau sagen und zwar das bewegt sich eindeutig in diese richtung und
wird sich vielleicht nicht nächstes jahr vielleicht über nächstes jahr aber wenn das so weiter geht
auf absehbare zeit wird sich stadia auf dem google friedhof wiederfinden und vielleicht haben wir
ja glück und zumindest der chromecast ultra wird von irgendwelchen leuten gehackt und man kann es
auch als cooles gerät verwenden für custom firmware 10 games
wollte ich nämlich noch gucken habe ich auch vorhin extra gespeichert auf dem tablet
genau spiele die grafisch immer noch gut sind aber ziemlich alt sind
wenn du prinz marcus bist baust du ein haus neben dem stadia so aber dann hast du deine
45 millisekunden reaktionszeit also wenn ich ein pri... wenn ich ein haus neben dem stadia server bau und ich
nur 45 millisekunden reaktionszeit hab da wäre das ganz schön fail
most video games look way nicer now than they did back in 2000s but there are some games that hold
up pretty damn well today and gaming here are 10 games from the 2000s that graphically still hold
up starting off from number 10 now this game is unique on this list because it's not really a demanding
game with wild realistic graphics and heavy team fortress 2 instead team fortress 2 because of
its stylized look which was super unique at the time that has helped to age way more gracefully
than other games of that era with more realistic art styles choosing to go with a bright bold
color palette instead of just revisiting the gray and brown more realistic designs of games like half life 2 and portal and making unique characters with fun exaggerated proportions rather just going with the standard character designs of the time was a bold move and it definitely paid off here the whole vibe was pulled together with the games maps as well carrying that aesthetic over into the level design and creating fun interesting maps that still had that cool... leider ist das ein game was unter dem welfluch von version 3 leidet beziehungsweise
irgendwie das bekommt doch den relaunch jetzt das game hat es definitiv verdient weil das hat
hat wenig liebe bekommen es gibt noch von seagull gibt es noch alte alte tf2 videos von irgendeiner lade
war ja richtig gut damals und vor allem von dieser ganzen physik physik geschichte aber generell das
gesamtpaket auch die gesichter und die animation zwar wegweisen ich meine es ist krass was ich in fünf jahren getan hat das ist half life 1 von 98 wo immer das ist half life 1 von 98 und das ist half life 2 von was 2004 also was ich in 5 6 jahren getan hat ist schon heftig so viel hat sich definitiv die letzten 5 6 jahren nicht getan
und steam genau das sieht doch immer noch ganz gut aus gut es hat auch ein paar updates gekriegt aber trotzdem
auch dringend
und
das
Es geht um die Details, die GTA 4 richtig macht.
Speziell mit dem Set-up, das Liberty City ist, das aufgrund von New York City basiert.
Es tut einen tollen Job, New York zu erzeugen und wirklich zu fangen, was es so ist,
oder zumindest, was es vor zehn Jahren so war.
Von der Schnauze in den Straßen zu den Feuerescapes,
ich fühlte mich, als ob ich in einem lebendigen, atemberaubenden New York City wanderte.
Natürlich, ja, du kannst es mit Mods noch besser sehen,
aber wir reden hier besonders um den Basis.
Besser ein Stadia-Kraft.
Ist ja...
Also, including some famous landmarks, such as the Empire State Building,
the Fire Iron Building...
GTA ist halt einfach nicht beides, eher hier.
Rockstar's always been good with nailing the settings of their games,
so it's really no surprise, but they nailed it here as well.
And at number seven, at least for me, Far Cry 2 definitely felt like a game
that was ahead of its time, both in systems and in visuals.
Optisch sah das richtig gut aus.
Do you remember a bunch of people complaining that Far Cry...
Far Cry 2 bei Release sah richtig gut aus.
Auch diese ganze Geschichte, mit dass du irgendwie Bäume anzünden konntest und so was...
Richtig cool.
Allerdings war das Gameplay von Far Cry 2 übelster Crap.
Ich hab das vielleicht zwei Stunden gespielt, dann wurd's mir zu doof.
Aber man sieht die Ursprünge von Half-Life 3 ganz gut,
weil diese Camp-Einnehmen-Geschichte und so was,
das hattest du in Far Cry 2 auch schon.
Mit Far Cry 1 hat das Ganze übrigens überhaupt nix mehr zu tun gehabt, ja.
Hat ja auch mit Crytechnics nix mehr zu tun gehabt.
Hab ich Half-Life 3 gesagt?
Bei Far Cry 3.
Du hast permanent irgendwelche Melaria-Anfälle gekriegt in Far Cry 2.
Ja, das stimmt, das sah wirklich verdammt gut aus damals schon.
Das ganze constantly-suffering-from-Melaria-Fits-und-all-that-Stuff,
das ist cool, das ist sicherlich cool.
Aber visuell, das hält definitiv an.
Auf zu Nummer 6 haben wir die Chaos-Theorie von Splinter Cell.
Das ist eine, die mich bis heute noch überrascht, wie gut es aussieht.
Das war einer der ersten Spiele, in denen ich dachte,
sie haben wirklich Licht geliefert.
Und die Differenz zwischen Licht und Dunkelheit.
Ich glaub, Chaos-Theorie hab ich nie gespielt.
Es gibt auch Splinter Cells, ein Stealth-Spiel.
Daher findest du dich oft in der Dunkelheit schlinken.
Und du kannst dir viel Zeit sagen, wie man in die Dunkelheit wirklich dunkel gemacht hat.
Zumindest waren es gute Stelzer-Games.
Mit Eax-Audio-Effekts, ja, so muss das sein.
Ja, Bioshock ist stylemäßig eines der hübsches U-Games überhaupt.
Genauso wie Mario Galaxy hat es jetzt ein komplett anderes Game, ja.
Mario Galaxy hat so einen passenden Style, dass das trotz der Kackauflösung einfach
gut aussieht.
Du denkst dir bei Games, die versuchen zu übertrieben realistisch zu sein oder in einer
Kategorie von der Grafik viel besser sind als in der anderen, sticht das immer raus.
Aber du hast Games, sagen wir mal, wie Bioshock, wie Mario Galaxy, da hast du Games, die sind
so gut aus einem Guss, dass du eigentlich gar nicht mehr richtig mitkriegst, dass du
halt auf Grafik auf dem PC kommst.
Echt, davon gibt's ja Re-Made.
So alt ist das schon, ey, fuck, es ist doch Bubbles.
Crysis sieht heute noch gut aus.
Danach hat sich Crytek gedacht, ey, lass uns doch 85.000 Studios weltweit aufmachen und
pleite gehen.
Stimmt ja.
Ah, das Main-Game war besser.
Ja, Uncharted, generell die ganze Uncharted-Serie ist definitiv grafisch auch ein Riesen-Highlight
auf der PS3.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass Uncharted 4 irgendwie schlecht ist oder so, das ist eindeutig noch
besser, hübscher.
Aber ich muss sagen, Uncharted 2, bei mir, ich finde ja insgesamt, von der Story her
und vom Gesamtpaket und so, mir gefällt immer noch das 1er am besten, aber das 2er hatte
eine Sache, was ich selten so gut gesehen habe, das war die Interaktion von Drake mit der Umgebung.
Er hat sich nicht einfach gegen die Wand gelaufen, sondern hat sich in die Kurve, um die Ecke
gelehnt.
Die Animation war wirklich das, was für mich, ich meine, der Rest sah auch gut aus, aber
die Animation war für das, was für mich Uncharted ausgemacht hat und das habe ich selten, Max
Pain 3 auch richtig, richtig gut in der Richtung, aber das habe ich selten so gut gesehen wie
in Uncharted.
Ja ohne Cole, das einzige Spiel, was ich für die Vita habe, ist das Uncharted Game.
Ich habe mir damals, ich war so blöd, und habe mir bei Release eine Vita gekauft.
Richtig debatet, wann coldest du wieder Junge, jeden Tag, du musst halt nicht unbedingt immer
on stream.
Ich muss euch ja sagen, also jetzt mal ehrlich Leute, Uncharted Grills, Chloe oder Nadine,
eh, hieß die überhaupt Nadine, ist die Nadine, ne nicht Nadine, nicht Nadine, Nadine können
wir da auch mit rein, wie hieß die andere, Elena, Elena, wie komme ich jetzt auf Nadine,
wisst ihr was mich, was mich, was mich echt gerade ein bisschen irritiert hat, habt ihr
die Autovervollständigung gesehen, die ich eingegeben habe, Uncharted, Nadine, feed,
was ist mit den Leuten wieder los, was ist mit den Leuten wieder los, ok Leute, Chloe,
Nadine oder Elena, Chloe beste, Elena, Elena, ja ja, Leute der Chat weiß Bescheid, der Chat
weiß Bescheid, Elena, eindeutig, Elena beste, die Füße,
jetzt nicht, weil Elena glaub ich die angenehmste von allen drei ist, sondern auch weil Elena
die hübscheste von allen drei ist, das ist in Kombination, oder kannst du mir was willst
du sagen, ja?
Weil ich eigentlich der Einzige, der gedacht hat, als er hier flimm das erste Mal gesehen
hat, dass der Typ quasi in der Story dann dich verarscht, ich finde allein schon wie
sie das Charaktermodel gebastelt haben, war das, sobald du das gesehen hast, zum ersten
Mal klar, dass der nicht debatet, sorry Spoiler, Spoiler, für ein zehn Jahre altes Game, sorry,
für ein zehn Jahre altes Game, sorry Spoiler, Spoiler, für ein zehn Jahre altes Game, sorry,
für ein zehn Jahre altes Game, sorry, sorry, für ein zehn Jahre altes Game, sorry, für
ein zehn Jahre altes Game, sorry, für ein zehn Jahre altes Game, sorry, für ein zehn
Jahre altes Game, sorry, für ein zehn Jahre altes Game, sorry, für ein zehn Jahre altes
Game, sorry, für ein zehn Jahre altes Game, sorry, für ein zehn Jahre altes Game, sorry,
für ein zehn Jahre altes Game, sorry, für ein zehn Jahre altes Game, sorry, für ein
zehn Jahre altes Game, sorry, für ein zehn Jahre altes Game, sorry, für ein zehn Jahre
altes Game, sorry, für ein zehn Jahre altes Game, sorry, für ein zehn Jahre altes Game,
sorry, für ein zehn Jahre altes Game, sorry, für ein zehn Jahre altes Game, sorry, für
ein zehn Jahre altes Game, sorry, für ein zehn Jahre altes Game, sorry, für ein zehn
Jahre altes Game, sorry, für ein zehn Jahre altes Game, sorry, für ein zehn Jahre altes
Game, sorry, für ein zehn Jahre altes Game, sorry, für ein zehn Jahre altes Game, sorry,
für ein zehn Jahre altes Game, sorry, für ein zehn Jahre altes Game, sorry, für ein
zehn Jahre altes Game, sorry, für ein zehn Jahre altes Game, sorry, für ein zehn Jahre
altes Game, sorry, für ein zehn Jahre altes
Game, sorry, für ein zehn Jahre altes Game, sorry, für ein zehn Jahre altes
Game, sorry, für ein zehn Jahre altes
Game, sorry,
für ein zehn Jahre altes Game, sorry, für ein zehn Jahre altes
Game, sorry, für ein zehn Jahre altes
Game, sorry,
für ein zehn Jahre altes
für ein zehn Jahre altes Game, sorry,